i gotta get that lucille wink from you
there it is jessica walter has died
a rep for the actress confirmed that
jessica died in her sleep at home in new
york city
on wednesday she celebrated her 80th
birthday
in january do you know your nostrils
flare out into little wings when you're
mad
in a statement from her daughter brooke
bowman she said of her mother quote
her greatest pleasure was bringing joy
to others through her storytelling
both on screen and off jessica's
entertainment career spanned
60 years and she was most well known for
playing the iconic role of lucille bluth
on arrested development here's some
money go see a star war
jessica's co-stars took to social media
to pay tribute
jason bateman tweeted rest in peace
jessica walter what an incredible career
filled with amazing performances i will
forever remember my time with her
watching her bring lucille bluth to life
she was one of a kind
all my love and thoughts to her family
you know jason
besides being a wonderful actor is truly
one of the most decent human beings i
have
ever met actor in business whatever
will arnett wrote i'm fortunate to have
had a front row seat to her brilliance
for 25 years
[Music]
this is my busty buster
tony hale tweeted she was a force and
her talent and timing were
unmatched rest in peace mama bluth henry
winkler wrote
it was an honor to watch her comedy
explode from the very first row
alia shakat posted this portrait of
jessica to instagram and in a reference
to the series
she wrote love you gengi david cross
called jessica a brilliant actress
and amazing talent he added i consider
myself
privileged and very lucky to have been
able to work with her
lucille bluth is one of tv's greatest
characters
get me a vodka rocks mom it's breakfast
add a piece of toast
jessica began her successful career on
broadway later starring in many
memorable roles in
film and tv she won an emmy in 1975
and later earned three more nominations
feel that she feels chubby she's a baby
jessica's most recent credit is for her
long-running role on archer
the animated series new season is
scheduled to premiere
later this year tell me a little bit
about your
career longevity what is the secret to
that just
hanging in there yeah hanging it's it's
about
60 years professionally working 60 years
how old am i people old and
if you have a passion for it it gets you
through i still i still love doing it